a man hunt is underway in the United
Kingdom that's after an inmate escaped
from a London prison on Wednesday
morning Daniel khif was in custody at
wesworth prison one of the country's
largest jails he's been accused of
terrorism offenses officials say that
it's almost certain that he had inside
help Jonah ho reports from
London Daniel Abed khif was being held
at London's wesworth prison when he's
believed to have slipped out of the
kitchen where he was working on
Wednesday morning strapping himself to
the underside of a food delivery van the
former British Army soldier being held
pending trial on terrorism charges was
last seen dressed in a prison Cook's
outfit he's now on the run with a major
Manhunt underway to catch him he could
be anywhere in the country at the moment
and yes of course we're mindful of the
risk of him potentially leaving the
country we're focusing our efforts in
London at the moment so we have
counterterrorism officers now deployed
across London working with colleagues
from across the Metropol police and our
partner agencies to try and find him
here opposition parties are asking
awkward questions like why a person
being held on terrorism charges was in a
category B prison rather than a higher
security facility and also about the
effect of budget cuts on the prison
service said to be overcrowded and
underresourced this was a a catalog of
of Errors um this Escape or appears to
be I mean we haven't had the the report
from the investigation yet but it seems
to me that a lot of procedures um were
not done or not done properly who was on
duty that morning in what roles ranging
from the kitchen to the prison gate what
protocols were in place were they
followed wassworth prison has an
official capacity of 1,800 but
successive inspections have found it to
be 60 to 80% overcrowded the government
has ordered an urgent investigation and
even long cues formed as police searched
potential ports of exit the government's
Justice Minister promised khif will be
found and made to face Justice Jonah Hal
Al jazer
London joining me now to discuss this is
John podmore he's a former governor of
belmarsh bingston and sside prisons and
he joins us from gler in the UK what's
the most surprising thing about all of
this to you
sir well I mean there are three uh
surprising components here one that he
was in wesworth which I think as has
been described as a category B prison um
I was governor as you said of um
belmarsh um dealt with a lot of category
a prisoners dealt with a lot of people
on terrorist charges and and terrorist
convictions and that's where he should
be that's where the security is at its
at its highest um and that was the most
appropriate location for him so I don't
understand why he was at uh wwor even
even more um curious is that he was due
to appear at woit Crown Court and W
Crown Court is um a key part of the
function or servicing that that court is
a key part of the function of of bmar so
why he was transferred out I I don't
know it's it's deeply deeply worrying
that um he held a position of
responsibility he was on remand yet he
held a uh
high-profile much sought after what we
would call a plum job in in in the
kitchen remand prisoners because you
know they can their status can change
very quickly they may need to go to
court they tend not to get much in the
way of employment which is not to say
they shouldn't have employment Education
and Training but uh because they are
more transient uh prison population they
tend not to get those jobs but uh in in
any event um the kitchen is is where you
put trusted uh prisoners who have been
properly assessed s um where they're
seen as what what what do prison
authorities what questions do they need
to be asking
now well they they need to I mean there
are there are two things I mean they
need to be asking about why he was in
wesworth that's the first thing they
need to be asking why he held a um Prime
position of responsibility in the jail
where he had access to vehicles and
goods and services coming coming in and
out of the jail um and there are two
possible um answers to this it could
well be that he was resourceful you he
was a trained army officer so he's uh W
imagine he's reasonably resourceful so
whether he was opportunist
opportunistic um saw a gap in
security exposed that um and escaped on
the the so he escaped under a Lor that's
considered a fairly basic security
breach isn't
it yes um and there you know Alex CH was
talking about protocols there are
protocols in place that any vehicle
coming into a prison and any vehicle
going out of a prison should be searched
on top underneath and inside that
clearly didn't happen now that might not
have happened because of incompetence uh
of Staff who were not well trained not
well LED not well supported or it could
be because there's some form of
collusion the answer I don't know that
is for uh what I'm glad to see is an
independent inspection and not an
internal investigation which is the norm
so the opposition in the UK has strongly
suggested that this may actually reflect
chronic underfunding and underst
Staffing of Prisons do you think that
might be the
case yes the entire prison system is
chronically underfunded chronically
under resourced um the staff that it
does have that one there are twoo few of
them and their experience levels are low
I mean the average the average
experience level in a lot of jails you
know 50 60% of the prison officers have
less than two or three years experience
and with that absence of experience goes
you know an ability and inability to get
security absolutely right but this is
not just about onword this is about a
wider malays of the prison system in the
UK it it is failing and has been failing
for many years um and this is one uh
example of security failures that there
are many others and we have a Chief
Inspector of Prisons we have a Chief
Inspector of pration who is constantly
cataloging them the problem is is that
we have prisons ministers who change by
the hour but we have prison um Senior
Management that's been there for decades
and not not being challenged enough into
finding out why the prison system is bad
we we can easily blame resources we can
easily blame overcrowding those are
issues but it goes beyond that John
podmore former governor of multiple
prisons in the UK thank you very much
for joining us
today my pleasure sir